[Music]
so you got mugged huh mr donaghy and you
caught the guy who did it good for you
oh no len uh tracy is helping me with
this but i can see how you went there i
have a criminal skull shape len
commissioner kelly and i are friends we
have competing columns and irish
arguments weekly america's only all caps
magazine but ray hasn't returned my
phone call and i know that you were once
a uh police officer i was part of a
special task force of very young looking
cops who infiltrated high schools
[Music]
how do you do fellow kids what
so i'm glad you called me mr donaghy i
checked with my contacts on the force
and got you this free pamphlet liv i
don't want a pamphlet i want a show of
force a demonstration of who's in
control of this city i want a cop on
every corner
look that's not gonna happen it's just
one mugging wait a second
where did you get that suit i'm not
embarrassed i get all my outfits at ann
taylor loft their clothes fit my body
and my budget exactly budget
you have no interest in helping me
you're one of them what do you make five
figures 40 grand a year
but don't let the woman who's
blackmailing me know that and the police
have no interest in helping me either
despite the hundreds of dollars i pay
every year in taxes they think that i'm
the enemy and we have no choice but to
take matters into our own hands i agree
you do
oh no
you